and he's been good for the Flyers good upand
Comer good back up to Carter Hart and here comes
the first odd man Rush of the game this is what
the Flyers acle at the first shot save made by
UC Soros Tyson forer the youngster a rookie who's
really hit his stride he's played outstanding here
and now a short-handed Rush another save for Soros
SOS has had to be sharp in the opening minute of
the game two full speed r chances Nashville will
start on the power play now one for two in their
win over Montreal in their last game that was
Sunday night there's Cody glass getting some power
play time to start things off Roman Yosi speeds
it over Uso Parson now glass on the opposite side
keeps it moving with the captain near side of
angelista Yosi again to The Far Side here it's
a shot by Tommy Novak I would say they're up
there with one of the hardest working clubs in
the league as well so should be a lot of fireworks
tonight Nashville flip flops the units now it's
the top unit a shot by by forsberg another save
for Arison back and forth no whistles I feel
with this year's team and the way that they're
playing they're just not a lot of whistles it's
it's back and forth hav't been a lot of shots
but a lot of possession changes forb to carry a
score it looked like it was Gus
nqu that tipped it as that cross
I speed from forsberg to ker created
the action and Nashville is on the
scoreboard well just as I say there wasn't
a lot of shots what happens we get one and
it goes in the back of the net and look at carer
they get it Nyquist right through the middle this
is beautiful perfectly Faceoff win for Michael
McCarron ker had just enough Loft on that one
and now a great tip pass in on a breakaway ainson
is St by Soros boy he delayed he looked like he
waited it out got the shot away but Soros made
the stop watch interception you you mentioned
the timing right there on the outside watches
not shooting he tries to pull in and go around
Soros he splits and gets it with the pad on
the post Ain had nowhere to go Shen defending
him well there kind of disrupting a Atkinson's
ability to get the the puck up there's the stick
he said pay attention to the way they go through
the ne it's going to be a quick game loose puck
in front a great save by Arison rebound behind
digging forward as surewood Evangelista looking
it's a full scramble it's still going Yosi has
it pulls it out Evangelista can't check it in
oh my God it was just sitting there look at all
the six in front of the goalie there's three of
them my God there's three of them I've never
seen York with a good keep in forer sends it
side to side there's a shot of blocker save
by Soros he punched it way out deep rescued
by connector cross in the high slot here's
connecting out front Frost from the circle
Couer they move it forer that kicked high off the
glass everybody ducking for cover good retrieval
by the Flyers now the side of the net Frost
rotates around Couer goes to the net front
they got it to Couer tries to tuck it in Soros
is on it terer trying to help him out as he was
down on the ice so Soros could secure it yeah that
that was great and Ryan mcdunn out there too and
that's exactly he's talking about with car got
to get clear as you get in this situation a lot
of abbreviated power plays in Montreal on Sunday
trenin comes up and lose back but his pass goes
back the other way here's a shot Sav made by Soros
rebound pinballing around and cleared by trennan
another big save for UC Soros after that errant
pass and Morgan Frost had the more you go to the
box the harder it is to be effective and get in
the flow of the game and have all this strength
I guess and power in your legs when you're thring
all this one right in front H just over the crossb
by siss rebound Tren and tried to stuff it in and
Aron able to cover oh that was fluttering ever so
close to looping under the bar wow this line in
particular this this line and the Predators lead
the league in chances off the cycle and this is
just a for check they get the puck back they go
in they get Arison to 24 of age and now a steal by
kkny it's a two-on-one for the Flyers kkny sends
it across what a save by Soro rebound sent to the
net and batted Away by MCD comes up big and why
wouldn't it be look right here conne strips
MCD with the puck he's going to pass it over
to Ty Forester and Soros full split absolutely
rubs him he's got to get this Puck up he gets it
up a little bit but SOS beats the play there cor
Smith gets it to all kinds of action going on in
front of the net penalty call coming up on the
Flyers wasan fights to keep possession he gets
dumped extra attacker is on forsberg in the game
Chen shoots rebounds score they're going to be
steam Michael McCarron found the loose puck in
the slot after Shen took it initially it was block
never got through and the Predators have grown the
lead to two nothing well here's and hammering it
to the net gets deflected up high McCarron gets
it with his skate stops it kicks it to his stick
blade and then tucks it in the net Shen just
gets it through but half the way is going to be
steamed because he's arguing that he touched this
during that sequence before that sequence and the
Predators kept going no whistle Shen to the net
and big sexy now evanel Lisa trying to get free
man comes out of the Penalty Box nation's got to
hurry back numbers for the Flyers far across cier
scores a big lift for the Flyers they go through
all kinds of adversity they have outplayed the
Predators throughout the second period and they
cut the lead in half with just 23 seconds to go
in the period in a period you're going to get
burnt and right here you you're going in on
the play the penalties expiring you're trying
to attack you missed that play two onone here
and look at that Patience by cier watch this
he's going to bring it out and then just tuck
it right under you see the boot break right
there just went right under that boot break
rist the line resets the offense with 15 seconds
to go shuttled out of there by Fabro a good touch
pass and Smith gets up Cole Smith turns the
corter shoots sa to the rebound popped out of
there as well this Puck out right here you can see
them battling and then Cole Smith gets some speed
here chips by jumps around he's trying to like
sneak five hole get saved there by Arison gets
another chance and as soon as this got that shot
there he went turned around right to the bench
got off he knew he needed fresh legs in there
just little too high there turns and shoots
that one got through good save there for the
young goal tender Samuel Aron battle for this
Puck and now a three on one here come the Flyers
and another play rebound score Brads are Furious
tra sanheim got the loose Puck and buried it to
tie the hockey game at two they are Furious they
think there should have been a penalty called
in the neutral zone and it's happened on both
sides tonight but because something a battle
along the boards over here with far now here
come the Flyers two on one ainson looks he shoots
and a save made by Soros with the blocker battle
for the first possession won by the Predators
Yosi he'll take it down with forsburg Roman
Yosi forsburg in oil forsburg eyes the net
shoots save made by Aon the rebound score yes
sir look at the battle here to get possession
O'Reilly right there and cier nice little hand
off forsberg does a loop he's got space and he's
attacking the net he's a shooter he's shooting
look at that puck he knew it he knew it slipped
behind him what a great look there at forsburg
that's why you go to the net after you shoot
that puck he knew he didn't have it and look
at him right there reaching in he gets low and
Tucks it in for an overtime win 18 seconds in